- [Narrator] Birria may
be new to some of you
but this dish has been around for decades.
The juicy, slow cooked
meat stew is often served
for special occasions
and you'll soon see why.
It's truly a melt in your mouth experience
that honestly deserves its own holiday.
Today we celebrate its evolution
by not only showing you how
to make delicious birria,
but also how to serve it taco style.
(relaxing music)
Birria originated in the
Mexican state of Jalisco,
but it's believed to
have grown in popularity
after Don Guadalupe Zarate
set up a birria stand
in Tijuana in the 1950s,
Birria is traditionally
made with goat meat,
but reportedly Zarate eventually began
to prepare it with beef.
We tested a variety of meats,
goat, beef, lamb, and pork.
While we loved the classic goat,
we decided to use beef for our recipe.
It's more widely available
but still packed with flavor.
Now that we've picked our protein,
let's talk cuts.
We want fatty, meaty cuts.
In this recipe we're using a
mix of boneless beef chuck roll
and bone-in beef short ribs.
Bones are packed with collagen and flavor,
adding richness to our consome
that will have your lips
sticking together in a good way.
Consome is a savory brothy sauce.
It's what we'll be dipping
our tacos in later.
Before we get to cooking,
we want to season our meat with salt.
Don't skimp on the salt here, people.
We want to coat our meat completely.
Then we'll chill our
seasoned meat in the fridge
for at least four hours.
Seasoning our meat before
we sear it is going
to give us that crispy brown crust
and lock in more flavor.
All right, let's move on to our chilies.
Everyone uses their own
combo of dried chilies.
Today we're using or Morita,
Guajillo, and Ancho chilies.
Morita chilies for their
spice and smokiness,
Guajillo chilies for
their spice and sweetness,
and Ancho chilies for their dark richness.
We'll cover chilies with warm water
and let them soften
for about five minutes.
Then we'll remove the
seeds and stems like this
or under running water
and set the peppers aside.
But the spice doesn't stop there.
Incorporating more spices
and seasonings is going
to give us a well-balanced birria
that's layered with flavor.
Like chilies, everyone has their
go-to seasoning for birria.
Cinnamon, coriander
seed, bay leaves, cloves,
allspice, dried avocado leaves,
black peppercorns, cumin,
and Mexican oregano.
There are two types of oregano,
Italian and Mexican.
While they share the same name,
they have different tastes and aromas.
Italian or Mediterranean
oregano has minty undertones
while Mexican oregano has more
citrusy, earthy undertones.
For our recipe we are are using cinnamon,
coriander seed, black peppercorns,
allspice, and cloves.
We'll add them to a medium skillet
and toast them over medium heat.
Then we'll transfer them
to a spice grinder along
with our dried bay leaves
and Mexican oregano.
Toasting and grinding our spices
will give our spice mix a
fresher more vibrant flavor.
You want to grind them into
a fine powder like this.
Now it's time to cook our meat.
Traditionally the meat
is cooked underground.
We found the best way to replicate
that method was using a Dutch oven
with a tight fitted lid.
We'll remove our meat from the
refrigerator and pat it dry.
This will absorb any excess moisture
that could keep our meat
from getting an even crust.
Next we'll add a quarter cup of canola oil
to our pot over medium high heat.
Once the oil is shimmery,
add the meat and sear it on all sides.
We want to create this
really great crust all over,
also known as the Maillard reaction.
This process is going to
lock in yet another layer
of flavor to our braising liquid.
Once the meat is golden brown,
remove it from the pot and set it aside.
We're going to go ahead
and add our yellow onions
and quartered Roma tomatoes.
Sprinkle them with a tablespoon of salt
and let everything cook until the onions
and tomatoes begin to sweat,
about five to seven minutes.
Then we'll add our garlic
and cook until fragrant.
As if our kitchen
couldn't smell any better,
we're going to add the
spices we prepared earlier.
Cook until they're aromatic,
about two minutes.
Next, we'll add a little
apple cider vinegar
and eight cups of water.
Why water and not beef or chicken broth?
We're actually building our
own broth right in this pot,
so adding more beef or
chicken broth isn't necessary.
We'll return our seared meat to the pot,
toss in those chilies,
and bring everything to a boil.
Then we'll reduce our stew to a simmer
and cover it with a lid.
Okay, it's been about 30 minutes.
Let's give this a look.
See how our mixture has reduced
and the chilies have completely softened?
That's our cue that it's time
to remove our chilies and blend them.
We'll place them in a
high powered blender along
with two cups of our broth and blend.
Smooth and silky.
We'll add the chile
mixture back into our pot
and give it a stir.
Now we'll start topping our
stew with banana leaves.
The banana leaves are going
to add yet another layer
of flavor while also preventing
our meat from drying out.
Quick tip.
If you can't find banana leaves,
use aluminum foil.
And now for the hard part, waiting.
We're going to cover pot
and transfer it to the oven
to cook for 90 minutes.
It might be the longest
90 minutes of your life,
but hang in there.
See, that wasn't so bad.
We'll take off the lid and
remove the banana leaves.
Then remove the cooked meat from the pot,
place it in a large mixing bowl,
and start shredding.
The meat should easily pull away
from the short rib bones like this.
Now, it wouldn't be tacos
without tortillas and hey,
if you want to go the extra
mile and make your own,
more power to ya.
But store bought tortillas
are just as good for this
and when it comes to birria tacos,
our tortillas of choice are corn.
Here's when the magic happens.
Remember that warm flavorful
liquid left in our pot
after we removed the meat?
That's our consome.
See that thin layer of
fat sitting at the top?
We're gonna dip the tortillas in that
and lay them flat in our
lightly oiled skillet.
Pan frying our tortillas
in the fat is what's going
to give our tacos that
perfectly crisp crust.
We're crisping our tortilla on both sides
so our tacos don't fall apart.
There's some debate about
what we're about to do next.
We're going to top our
tortilla with cheese.
We're using shredded Oaxaca cheese here
because it's the best for melting,
but mozzarella cheese
is also a good option.
Then we'll add our shredded beef
and fold the tortilla in half,
and we'll cook it until
the cheese begins to melt.
Okay, time to flip.
Look at that golden brown
color and crispy crust!
This is what we want.
We'll continue cooking
to achieve the same on the other side.
They say you eat with your
eyes and they're not wrong.
Wow.
We came, we cooked, and
now we're more than ready
to consome these birria tacos.
All jokes aside,
we like to serve our birria
tacos with some cilantro,
pickled red onions, and lime.
And don't forget the consome
because dunking in your taco in it makes
for one delicious bite.
These birria tacos
are seriously worth every minute and mess,
so do us a favor and make this recipe,
and dip it like it's hot.
(relaxing music)